すげー結婚ブームが来てるならねすごいいろんな人が結婚してるよこれを言うしかない
なぁこの勢いに乗っています私はじめ冊を来月の2月の中4日に
結婚しません
たぶん皆さんも通ったくなる道だと思うんですけども絵本というものがございます絵が
書いてある本なんですけどもなんかねえ
泣きたいなっても僕のこと知ってる人ならわかると思うんですけどすごい泣いちゃうん
です涙もろいところがありまして結構なんかアニメとかね例がとか光化学系の引退試合
とか見ても泣いてるぐらいちょっといろいろないじゃんですけども絵本の中では泣け
ないほうがすごい多いみたいででちょっと色々調べた結果ですねなけれフォン
ランキングとかなんかいろんなのがあって近くの本屋さんに行ってちょっと投げ方は
なんだっ
今回買ってきましたあの僕行く種も涙もないつっても冊下に選んではなかないっすよ
さすが日本では泣かない何か動画とか動きがあるものじゃないとやっぱ北泣けないん
ですタウンっ
すげー風強いこんな僕じゃあ形でねすごいなきゃ入れない方を何冊か準備したのでそれ
で本当に何件かどうかは今回検証してみたいと思いますやばいよ23社に劣らない本
読んでないってたらもうねえい二つ目はこちらです100万回生きたねこ
これって恋の話だねこれはね食べにおいが読んだことある気がする大遠見動いある者に
100万部売れてるみたいでこ
なりますこれはねなんてねこう口コミにあったというか変化王道の泣ける話3というの
は絵本らしいので早速読んでいきたいとおもいます
寛解モスがない猫がいました
着もとございます
[音楽]
あ
読むだけだ読むだけだから何も期待しないでもんなわけないかどうかの検証ですから
ねっ
[音楽]
も泣きました
朝にやつようになって
[音楽]
ある日の52
うーん
カブねーいやーいい話ですね2にいいかな子だった絵もあるんですけど言葉が一言
ひとこと短いから足からがあるんですよね1文ずつに俺は何の話をしてんだいやほんと
になんか最後の方ど1分でちょっと急にグッときちゃったんでビビったんですけど本当
に話すって当たらな気がしなかったけどとても素敵なお話でした
ん
次次はこちらずっとずっと大好きだよ等学校の教科さに選ばれてるみたいですねこう
いうちょっとね大好きだよ桂馬ちょっとで怖いですね
ゆデー品なんで大丈夫しちゃっ f が世界で一番素晴らしい n です
[音楽]
僕はエレフィンに花タイムからをやって
ああああああ
あはい呼びます
[音楽]
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
huge こうするっ
[音楽]
n
ああああああ
でよかってもも今きっと入ってる僕ずっとずつ大好きだよっ
ウール
以後ですぞ問う
[音楽]
俺そう月光で4年どっちよ中皆泣いちゃうよ
ん you saw her クソヤバイなんかちょっとは俺もと吸ったら涙腺が弱
すぎるんですけど実は毒子供の頃にジョンっていう員がいたんですよ実感にねうんで
ペットと人間の差のあるじゃないですか
信頼関係とかグッときたものがありました
よかったうげーなーこんなそう学生4年度授業2でこんな音読したらみんなでも
スタンディングオベーションの拍手大喝采でマジで絵本で普通に泣いちゃうんだけど
タイガーこちらですちいさなあなたへっていうもんなんですけども
すごいせ55万部売れてるみたいですねこれは何かねそのことを受けたよりなんかその
お母さんとかでこちらの人の見ても後年間すごい感動する
みたいでめちゃくちゃなんかトップに上がってたんでちょっとしたらこれが最強なんか
もしれません
[音楽]
方印刷業で行きたいと思いますでは
半泣きぐらいエアーすごいでもいい話でした
よかったですよかった僕思ったんですけど
僕お母さんじゃなかったこれだ分ねあのお母さんが読んだらすごい
いけるのかなって思いましたなんか僕も館ちゃったことを思いながら読んだんですけど
グッときますね後から来る子これ後からグレパターンかも知れぬや良かったですごいね
全然で方向性がつかれたねぼくこれが一番だけなんですけどもえっなんかペットとか
ボケまずは子どもないんだ
いいので多分でまだそんなに心から入ることはちょっとまたできなかったんですけども
ペットが色々買ってたんでこっちはすごい共感できたので打ってきましたねと指で結果
絵本はいつ見てもいいものだよ
[音楽]
car
me
あっはぁ